a fight over post office funding with
potential implications for the election
is interfering with congressional talks
to renew coronavirus aid
president trump rejects the democrats
demand for 25
billion dollars in emergency funding for
the u.s postal service
plus another 3.6 billion to help states
process
mail-in ballots in november ben tracy is
at the white house ben
how is the president using politics to
say no
well this is money that the postal
service says that it needs especially to
handle what is expected to be a record
number of people voting by mail because
of the pandemic
but president trump is now making it
very clear that he doesn't want to do
anything to make voting by mail
any easier they can be forged
they can be captured they can be taken
president trump continues to make
unfounded claims about mail-in voting
in an interview thursday he admitted the
postal service needs more money to
handle ballots in november but he
doesn't necessarily want to provide it
now they need that money in order to
have the post office work so it can take
all of these millions and millions of
ballots
if we don't make a deal that means they
don't get the money but then at the
white house the president said he won't
veto a stimulus bill just because it has
funding for the post office
but that the democrats are asking for
too much
house speaker nancy pelosi questions
whether the white house
really wants to make a deal perhaps you
mistook them
for somebody who gave a damn that isn't
the case
democrats are also questioning the
motives of the new postmaster general
lewis dejoy de joy is a major republican
donor who has given more than one
million dollars to the trump victory
fund
when i see problems i work to solve it
cbs news has learned that after he took
over the postal service in june
he implemented cost cutting measures
that have led to delays in mail delivery
this internal postal service directive
obtained by cbs
news details an operational pivot in
which we may see mail left behind
or mail on the workroom floor or docs
which is not
typical dejoy declined our request for
an interview but in a statement said
despite any assertions to the contrary
we are not slowing down election mail
or any other mail now in recent
elections with a lot of mail-in ballots
there have been some delays in vote
counting but no evidence of fraud
despite his continued attacks on mail-in
voting records show that the president
and the first lady
just requested mail-in ballots for
florida's upcoming primary election
anthony